um i think one of the pieces that is so
interesting to me personally is
uh not only did you scale uh what was a
family business into this large national
chain
uh but you also were uh consistently
tapped for
your experience and knowledge so you sat
on the boards of domino's and sonic and
kind of these other types of businesses
and as you think back how much of
what you were learning as an operator uh
at
dunkin donuts gave you the ability to
kind of be a good board member be a good
sounding board and governor
of those other businesses right were
there a lot of kind of
um common lessons and common uh
challenges and obstacles that each of
these businesses were going through
or did you find that um even though they
were kind of in the food services space
these other businesses actually had
different challenges and different
things that they dealt with than
what you were dealing with as the
operator seat at duncan
well 35 years is a long run and it gave
me an opportunity to
make a lot of mistakes and
so those setbacks and successes i think
were helpful
as i served on other boards and
basically i
was a believer that i you know stick
stuck to my knitting
to things i knew so i only served on
boards or either
of uh chain operators small box
retailers i call them they either
utilize franchise
as a method of distribution and it could
have been in the automotive industry
or or it could have been in the food
service industry and
and i did find uh that on
on a board that there is an advantage to
having
an operator alongside other types
people who understand governance people
who understand maybe international
marketing what other issues that
business may be facing i think comprise
an effective award
but having a practitioner someone who's
been there done that's been helpful and
the answer to your question is yes
i found my experiences were
extraordinarily helpful
uh for example i was on one board uh
where we owned a
cotton uh a muffler repair and
non-muffled repair but the transmission
repair business
and we bought amco well i had experience
and
buying my competitor mr donut and
rebadging them to duncan
so that kind of experience could have
been very very useful
to to us as cotman as we bought amco
and merged the two brands together and
began to rebadge the stores under one
brand
so there were lots and lots of
experiences that i think i brought from
one
business even to the automotive
aftermarket repair business
that were useful absolutely and so
obviously a lot of what you've kind of
learned and i think built your career on
uh was finding the best people right and
kind of just whether it was uh
other board members uh executives
franchisees
just people people people when you
thought about people how much of this
was trying to find kind of
talent that was uh impressive but did
not yet
have kind of years and years of
experience doing something and so they
could kind of grow into the role
versus you wanted to go find people who
had already done the job let's say at
another company or on a bigger scale
like were you hiring for uh experience
or were you
more focused on hiring for kind of
potential and
competency there were three things that
i
utilized really the company utilized
the first was a real crisp
understanding of the assignment we
wanted somewhat to fill
and the better you define the assignment
the more likely you are to find a
candidate to come fulfill that
assignment
so i spent a lot of time thinking about
what is it
exactly where are we what do we need
filled in that job
so it's a definition of a job the second
philosophy or principle that we sort of
followed was
that we weren't looking for someone who
was
uh effective or knowledgeable in all
things we really really
we were a team culture we relied on
the complementarity of the skills in the
team
and it was no big including myself
no big admission not to be good at
everything certain things
we were thrown to be better at and not
so good at others
and the whole notion was to have in the
team the complementarity of skills
that we really would support and lift
each other up so long as you had mutual
respect
no backbiting which was not allowed in
our culture we
basically wouldn't put up with that and
the third thing was fit
and you had to fit the culture and the
culture in our case was
you know a teamwork aspirations yet
we were we were we liked to win uh
winning was a part of us just dna
so whenever we sort of achieved one
objective we set more lofty objectives
to
to spur us forward we we kept changing
all the time and kept growing
so i would say those were the three sort
of principles
that we utilized in some cases uh it
didn't require a lot of prior knowledge
and
in fact just the fit and the
complementarity of
the personalities might have been enough
depending on the assignment
yeah it's really interesting how um
you obviously did this for so long you
know exactly what you were looking for
and i think that that's a key
piece to this is uh if you just go out
and say hey we want to hire somebody you
obviously can make all kinds of mistakes
but when you say we specifically want to
hire somebody based on these three
criteria
that focus seems to drastically increase
the probability that you do it the right
way right
i agree absolutely